bonjour et bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit pour cette édition spéciale en ce
25 novembre dédié à l'ouverture de la
6ème édition du sky business des
conventions d'affaires organisé par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui permet aux entreprises du
bassin de saint quentin de rencontrer
d'identifier de nouveaux partenaires
pour faire simple de booster son
business au coeur d'un pôle d'excellence
celui de paris saclay bonjour jean
michel fourgous c'est la 6ème édition de
ce sky business day deuxième fois que
l'événement est 100% en ligne 1200
rendez-vous 600 participants attendus
des tables rondes aussi prévues tout au
long de la journée organisation plutôt
bien rodée pour ce rendez-vous pour
qu'il soit bénéfique à ses 400
entreprises elles qui vont qui vont pas
reprendre y prendre part on va
d'ailleurs rapidement voir quelques
images de la soirée de lancement c'était
hier soir vous avez déjà reçu les
différents chefs d'entreprises et
plusieurs personnalités pour une
agglomération comme saint quentin en
yvelines déjà très rapidement que le
business se porte bien c'est plutôt
nécessaire oui saint quentin en yvelines
c'est une agglomération très économique
qui croient dans l'économie de marché
qui croît dans la science dans la
technique dans l'économie dans le
numérique nous ça ce sont c'est ce qui
va faire sortir notre pays des
difficultés c'est c'est cette culture là
donc et d'ailleurs les principaux
dirigeants jean louis de saint quentin
viennent du monde économique connaissent
et ne tiennent pas un discours
idéologique
théorique 1 on veut nous du pragmatisme
on a peut être l'intelligence pour nous
c'est c'est pas simplement la capacité
d'abstraction de synthèse le brio
intellectuel sur les salons et sur les
plateaux c'est l'intelligence et de
trouver des solutions aux problèmes donc
la culture est très forte très fortement
remonté sur nos entreprises on vient
pour les faire gagner parce que je vous
rappelle qu'une entreprise c'est la
santé de la france 50% du chiffre
d'affaires ttc d'une entreprise et
redonner en solidarité
en sociales et fiscales l'abbé pierre
c'est l'entreprise s'est pas on aime
bien les associations qui font un bon
boulot si mais il faut faux pas il faut
rendre à césar ce qui appartient à césar
donc nous on est du côté de césar et ont
fait gagner nos entreprises nos emplois
marchands en priorité bien sûr même s'il
ya tout un tissu autour bien sûr il faut
un minimum le système public autour des
associations mais ne nous trompons pas
tout la priorité absolue c'est de sauver
nos entreprises qui sont menacés parce
que vous avez devant vous une d'abord
une guerre mondiale économique mais en
plus qui va être dramatisée par la
situation du coc vis de l'impact va être
très fort et donc on se prépare nous à
saint quentin à aider à protéger mais
sur accompagner nos entreprises et c'est
le but est bien sûr de ce script
business et la 6ème édition c'est un
très beau principe c'est pas un concept
intellectuel théorique pour séduire sur
les plateaux c'est une réalité et d une
petite entreprise a rencontré à
augmenter le nombre de ses prospects
l'un de ses contacts commerciaux donc le
nombre de ces affaires donc son chiffre
d'affaires donc ces emplois parce qu'il
faut gagner bien sûr pour pour créer des
emplois aujourd'hui on a six millions et
demi de chemin je crois que c'est 6000
ont 6 donc c'est plus que d'ailleurs
yasi ya cinq ans je rappelle que le
chômage augmente et j'entends beaucoup
de bêtises dites je sais que lui
campagne électorale ça fait c'est fait
stimulé l'imagination mais pour
l'instant on a encore augmenté le
chômage on a un million de personnes qui
n'ont pas il ya un million de postes qui
n'ont pas à trouver satisfaction il faut
régler tout ça en tout cas à s'implanter
en est bien sûr très mobilisés sur ces
sur ces objectifs là un chef
d'entreprise est aussi en plateau avec
nous pour cette ouverture jusqu'à
business des gens peu luminaires bonjour
bonjour c'était le directeur dax hall 7
vous importez vous distribuez des
solutions alternatives d'accessibilité
de sécurité vos clients aussi bien des
particuliers que des commerces des
collectivités administrations aussi vous
avez déjà participé par le passé à ce
rendez vous vous y participer encore
cette année quel bilan vous en fait et
qu'est ce que vous en attendez écoutez
nous c'est neutre
gérer c'est notre quatrième
participation business day
aujourd'hui le l'intérêt que nous avons
trouvé dans ce business days c'était
lorsque nous sommes arrivés sur saint
quentin en yvelines et donc sur sur
trappe il ya maintenant il ya maintenant
quatre ans
c'est de pouvoir retrouver des
prestataires locaux des petites
entreprises avec lesquelles nous
pourrions effectivement avoir des
échanges de deux business alors on a
moins trouvé de business en termes de
développement et de vente par contre
nous avons trouvé effectivement de
nombreux prestataires avec lesquels nous
travaillons toujours et qui
interviennent pour nous accompagner dans
notre développement voilà pour un
résultat déjà concrets cette année il ya
une tonalité particulière à cet
événement c'est l'événement prend les
couleurs du paris 2024 nous avons
également en ligne avec nous marie
barsacq bonjour
vous êtes la directrice impacté héritage
du comité d'organisation paris à 2024
ces jeux olympiques vont se dérouler
maintenant en français donc à parier
donc à saint quentin en yvelines dans un
peu moins de 2000 jours maintenant en
quelques mots ce sont de réelles
opportunités de développement économique
il faut que les entreprises s'en
saisissent dès à présent oui tout à fait
les jeux olympiques et paralympiques d
paris début 24 c'est pour nous le comité
d'organisation 2,5 milliard
d'opportunités économiques et vous savez
nous sommes donné comme objectif
d'offrir ces opportunités aux tpe pme
aux entreprises françaises alors
évidemment je le détaillerai peut-être
tout à l'heure on peut pas l'écrire
comme ça dans dans le document la
commande publique et contraignante mais
par ailleurs nous avons du coup des
stratégies qui nous permettent de
connecter les entreprises tpe pme
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire aussi à nos marchés
aujourd'hui ça marche puisque on a sur
les marchés que nous avons lancé 60%
dans un marché qui ont été attribués à
des tpe pme donc on est sur la bonne
voie on va maintenir le rythme mais je
vous détaillera peut-être salaires oui
c'est important de souligner que ce ce
business qui peut se développer concerne
tpe pme et pas uniquement les grands
groupes 1 7 petites entreprises sont
aussi au coeur de l'économie
c'était de la stratégie que nous
essayons de mettre en place et on est
ravi d'être là aujourd'hui pour la
partager avec les entreprises qui
participent à ce business day je vous
propose de poursuivre la conversation de
refaire un point juste comment sur les
sites yvelinois et principalement à
saint quentin en yvelines qui vont
accueillir c'est jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 on se retrouve juste
après
c'est officiel les yvelines vont
accueillir cette discipline sportive
pendant les jo de 2024 les sites ont été
définitivement adoptée le 17 décembre
dernier par le comité d'organisation
versailles organisera le cyclisme sur
route à proximité du château ainsi que
des épreuves de pentathlon moderne la
ville royale recevra également les
épreuves d'équitation un temps pressenti
à lamotte beuvron nous on savait que
toutes les chansons étaient avec nous
parce que c'est un site totalement
exceptionnel
qui accueille et puis l'environnement
à saint quentin en yvelines au vélodrome
nationale accueillera bien le cyclisme
sur piste et recevra les preuves des
scream du pentathlon moderne à une
centaine de mètres des courses de bmx
seront organisées enfin le golf national
recevra les épreuves golfique six ans
seulement après la ryder cup 2018 ce
qu'est le bien par rapport aux jeux
olympiques ce que ça va toucher
certainement une environ public un petit
peu plus large que la ryder cup parce
que la ryder cup peut-être que ça touche
est uniquement un public d'avertis de
golfeurs alors que les jeux olympiques
peut-être touché des personnes qui
peut-être sont pas susceptibles de
penser au golf alors en tant qu'activité
olympique enfin la colline d'elancourt
et ses 230 mètres d'altitude accueillera
les épreuves de vtt en 2004 une nouvelle
attendue depuis de longs mois par le v6
skyteam vous sert le club local qui
organise chaque année la revancharde les
compétitions cyclistes sur le site c'est
nous honoré parce que ça fait 25 ans bec
on reconnaît sur ce terrain là on a fait
la première revancharde
on est les seuls utilisateurs qui vous
vtt ici en compétition et pour nous
c'est une grande réussite c'est un
bonheur un bonheur partagé par tous les
adhérents du club les yvelines sont
aussi hautes de 2 sites paralympiques le
para équitation sera programmée dans le
parc du château de versailles et le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
les épreuves de paracyclisme sur piste
cette ouverture du sky business day se
poursuit sur l'antenne de tv 60,18 ce
matin il est question à présent de
l'impact économique pour le territoire
on parle souvent quand on parle de
chiffres du mil des millions de
visiteurs des vingt mille journalistes
des quatre milliards de téléspectateurs
généré autour de cet événement mais
est-ce qu'on peut chiffrer peut-être
pour une agglomération aussi le bilan
économique jean michel fourgous vos
services j'imagine travaille dessus ce
qu'on peut chiffrer un peu l'impact que
ça va représenter et que ça représente
dès à présent dans d'abord l'impact
médiatique on a du mal aujourd'hui elle
mesure et on l'a vu pour la ryder cup on
avait quasiment un milliard de
référencement du mot saint quentin en
yvelines mais c'est incalculable avec
les réseaux sociaux alors on y est plus
ou moins des systèmes comme qui nous
aide un mais bon donc quand vous dites 4
milliards en gros ça va être entre 4 et
5 milliards mon avis de gens qui vont si
c'est cela bien entendu que
une agglo comme saint quentin en
yvelines aussi vie d'une certaine
notoriété d'un certain sérieux pour
attirer les entreprises dont c'est à 28
2 de paris hors encombrement mais sur
osez quasiment 50 plus de 50% des
espaces verts ont donc c'est il ya une
qualité de l'air aussi à 51 par rapport
à d'autres
bien sûr ville beaucoup plus concentrés
donc donc voilà il ya c'est tous les
éléments d attractivité mais même là là
là là ce qu'il ya eu lieu au vélodrome
le hac cynodrome a eu une
une notoriété internationale dans le
monde entier gers était la référence
française on entendait parler de ça dans
l'antre du capital du monde pour écouter
très bien donc voilà ça nous aide à à
ras bord on a des très belles
universités aussi vous savez saint
quentin paris saclay première mondiale
en mathématiques ou dans des savons bien
entendu les gens s'ils voulaient faire
venir les talents et les capitaux alors
l'état lancé par les ingénieurs il
regarde tout de suite les écoles avant
d'accepter un poste bien sûr quelque
part donc bien entendu on a un gros
avantage là dessus un système scolaire
un système universitaire de quand même
très de très haut niveau donc tout cela
et puis notoriété puis des belle très
belle entreprise vous l'avez dit et puis
de gérer une bonne harmonisation entre
eux aussi l'appeler les politiques ici
on colle un profil très particulier donc
gérer une bonne harmonisation entre le
politique l'économique le social et la
proximité d'une des plus belles villes
du monde qui est bien sûr paris donc
voilà puis bien entendu ces événements
sportifs qui qui qui qui se marient bien
d'ailleurs avec la culture d'entreprise
ce quand vous voyez les valeurs d'un
champion olympique on en a vient encore
donc hier qu'ils étaient donc camille
lacourt cinq fois champion du monde de
natation vous voyez bien c'est les
valeurs les valeurs guides qui sont les
mêmes et on va redire en profiter à
saint quentin pour essayer de faire
changer l'état d'esprit de la france on
va déjà commencer à notre niveau mais
mais ces valeurs là mais mais mais elles
sont formidables celles qui font gagner
c'est celle qui vous sortent de ddd
disant nuit c'est d'abord la rigueur
pourrait de championnat si vous croyez
que on y va quand on veut pas du tout
ces essais c'est un sens de 2,2 à leur
talent à leur travail le sens de
l'effort durable c'est le travail en
équipe respect aussi de l'entraîneur de
larbitre oui ce que je veux dire en ce
moment
un banc respect de l'autorité bon donc
vous êtes tout la déclinaison des plus
belles valeurs qui font gagner un
individu qui vont gagner un pays donc je
vous dis on va pas se gêner pour mettre
le paquet avec nos entreprises avec nos
sportifs pour expliquer à tous nos
jeunes qui en a sacrément besoin parce
que on laisse un peu perdu dans ils
savent plus ce qui est vrai ce qui est
faux ce qui est bien ce qui est mal ce
qui est beau ce qui ne l'est pas
m'écouter nous alors expliqué avec nos
mots à nous un simple mais d'y régler
sujet verbe complément marie barsacq
pour parier à 2024 si on parle de niveau
économique quelles sont les entreprises
quels sont les secteurs plutôt qu'ils
peuvent bénéficier de ces géo et ses jo
paralympiques aussi alors il ya dix-sept
familles d'achats qui ont été
identifiées une cartographie dh assez
précises qui va être partagé je crois
par l'elysée qu'il de paris 2024 cet
après midi il ya des marchés qui vont
être lancés dès cette année en 2022
voire des marchés dans le nettoyage dans
le tri les déchets des marchés sur la
restauration des marchés aussi sur
l'achat d'équipements sportifs
d'équipements temporaires de barriérage
damman pour aménager les les gradins au
château de versailles par exemple donc
tout ça va être lancé dès 2022 début une
âme de il vraiment le début du lancement
de nous marcher on va avoir un pic entre
la fin 2022 et le début 2023 d'ailleurs
vraiment une grosse bosse de la montée
en charge de la publication de nos
marchés ce qui est important c'est que
on a fait vraiment ce travail de
cartographie de toutes ces familles
d'achats et du coup ça nous permet de le
partager aujourd'hui avec le tissu
économique pour aussi nous rendre compte
de ce qui existe sur le marché pour
mieux à lotir parce qu'on sait que la
clé pour donner accès à nos marchés aux
tpe pme notamment ça passe par là
lotissement et donc il faut que l'on
fasse ce travail et donc les rendez-vous
comme aujourd'hui sont aussi très
important pour nous pour mesurer quelle
est la capacité d'allotissement qu'on
peut proposer pour faire gagner
finalement un maximum d'entreprises
françaises et francilienne évidemment
aussi jean-paul minière vous qui êtes
président taxol entreprise de saint
quentin en yvelines dans votre domaine
d'activité vous ressentez déjà un effet
paris 2024
perspectives de développement de
business aussi au balo le ressent déjà
depuis quelques années parce que nous
avons une particularité c'est que nous
intervenons dans l'accessibilité
handicapés
le sport et vous l'évoquez monsieur
forme tout à l'heure nous l'accompagnons
également parce qu'on accompagne et
sportives paralympiques et non est très
engagé auprès de fédération auprès de
sportifs notamment des
sportifs qui a été médaillé à pékin
c'est à pékin cet été
et concernant paris 2024 nous avons dans
nos activités
une part importante qui est la location
de matériel qui est destiné à à
l'accessibilité dans un cadre
événementiel en d'autres termes
permettre à des personnes qui sont par
exemple en fauteuil roulant franchir
quelques marches accéder à une scène etc
et nous intervenons déjà historiquement
sur roland garros on nous intervenons
également sur
sur le sur les sur les salons foires et
salons du bourget et autres et paris
2024 il se trouve que nous accompagnons
déjà nous accompagnons déjà le comité de
candidature à l'époque pour permettre à
des
girelles entourage à l'organisation et
notamment dans l'organisation et
certaines personnes qui sont en fauteuil
roulant qui leur ont permis de monter
sur scène pour pouvoir témoigner
lors de lors de leurs différentes
conférences et nous continuerons à le
faire donc ça c'est la partie
événementielle avec paris des lignes 24
et ensuite pour le pour le reste il y a
effectivement tout là toutes les
infrastructures qui vont être
construites 9 donc il ne nous concerne
pas directement puisqu'elles sont
réputés étant accessible et mr
évidemment mais par contre pour toute la
partie événementielle toutes les
infrastructures qui sont des bâtiments
beaucoup plus anciens sur laquelle on
peut avoir des problèmes de mobilité je
pense au parc des princes je pense à des
problèmes de de transfert de volume le
transfère de personnes pmr par exemple
sur bercy ou sur des bâtiments des
bâtiments historiques là nous pouvons
intervenir vous faites partie des
entreprises référencées ça c'est ça
signifie quoi et ça permet quoi
concrètement alors
en fait nous sommes effectivement
référence est à la fois sur paris 2024
soit sur la structure puisque
la structure des canaux qui est là la
structure qui accompagne des entreprises
en économie sociale et solidaire ne
sommes pas économie sociale et solidaire
mais nous les accompagnons et de façon
tout à fait naturelle
j'irai que en témoignage la démarche est
extrêmement simple extrêmement rapide à
ses besoins dessus ce qui est ce qui est
également appréciable c'est que de façon
extrêmement régulière on n'a pas
nécessité d'être envahis permanence sur
les la publication des appels d'offres
sont les marchés puisque nous recevons
des newsletters avec des marchés qui
sont proposées par paris de 1024 600 une
démarche beaucoup plus simple prenez des
tpe pme n'ont pas le temps d'être en
veille permanente par rapport à ça et
pour appuyer ce que 10e avec le thème
d'un lotissement je trouve que c'est une
démarche qui est vraiment
très intéressante puisque je prends
l'exemple qui est pas de notre parti qui
est la partie traiteur sur des gros
événements habituellement c'est plutôt
des traiteurs nationaux ou
internationaux qui vont répondre à deux
sur l'ensemble des sites la la démarche
a été
j'irai de vrais mandat le tir par par
site et donc chaque chaque site local
pour avoir son propre traiteur qui
pourraient différents donc on va voir a
dit à traîter différend entre le
vélodrome par exemple et la colline
la colline de l'encours ce qui permet
véritablement des petites structures
locales de pouvoir acte est candidate et
marie barsacq on vient d'entendre un des
témoignages d'un responsable
d'entreprise dans son travail est
l'impact sur son business concrètement
paris 2024 la structure intervient comme
ans auprès de ces tpe pme de quelle
manière vous les conseillez quels sont
les dispositifs d'accompagnement pour
aussi les chefs d'entreprise qui nous
suivraient qui se diraient ben oui à de
l'opportunité mais qui va m'aider à tout
ça il ya plusieurs axes de travail pour
nous le premier axe qui était le plus
important c'était dessus du sourcing ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure pour
qu'on s'assure que les entreprises
savent qu'il va y avoir des opportunités
économiques et donc c'est les
plateformes que l'on a lancé très tôt
dans le projet le ce sujet économique
était le premier sujet à l'agenda de
l'héritage des jeux et donc en 2019 on a
ouvert ses plateformes entreprises 2024
porté par le medef et es s2000 24
portées par les canaux qui évoqué
monsieur à l'instant donc ces
plateformes elle permettre de deux
sources et les entreprises qui sont
éligibles au marché des jeux et comme le
disait monsieur très justement de leur
donner de l'information économique
qualifiée sur les sujets qui les
intéressent pour qu'elle ne loue pas les
étapes de publication des jeux et
puisqu'elle se prépare qu'elle faisait
aussi le temps de s'associer à d'autres
entreprises pour pouvoir garantir leurs
chances de remporter le marché ça aussi
c'est un élément important je me permets
juste une petite parenthèse là dessus
pour aussi vous dire que nous se source
in sur ces plateformes est donc c'est
pour ça que c'est important de faire
passer le message aujourd'hui il va nous
être utile quand on va faire rentrer des
plus gros sur les marchés parce que vous
le savez un moment donné il ya quand
même des grosses entreprises qui vont
vouloir venir et là on va avoir la
capacité grâce à ce sourcing qualifié de
pousser les tpe pme les entreprises et
l'économie sociale et solidaire au prix
de ces grandes entreprises pour répondre
à nos marchés c'est parce que la
deuxième étape de notre fusée c'est une
stratégie d'achat assez ambitieuse là
dessus puisque on demande à chaque
structure qui répond à nos marchés de
répondre à 5 questions qu'est ce que
vous faites sur le marché qui le donnait
en termes d'économie circulaire qu'est
ce que vous faites pour minorer votre
impact carbone qu'est ce que vous faites
pour générer de l'innovation sociale en
gros pour inclure des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi qu'est ce que vous
faites pour l'inclusion des personnes en
situation de handicap et en forme qu'est
ce que vous faites pour créer de la
valeur sur les territoires quand une
entreprise notamment une grosse
entreprise elle va devoir répondre à ces
cinq questions et bien du coup elle va
se tourner vers les petites entreprises
qu'on va me pousser grâce à notre
sourcing pour pouvoir répondre parce que
les grosses entreprises qui ne font rien
sur le handicap mais en revanche
puisqu'elles vont devoir répondre à la
question sur le handicap elles vont
aller voir une entreprise qu'on aura
source et et qui elle peut lui apporter
la solution est donc elles vont répondre
en groupement à notre marché c'est aussi
ça la démarche initiée on s'y prend tôt
on s'y est pris tôt pour faire ce
sourcing et donc on est assez confiant
sur la capacité aujourd'hui on va
pouvoir avoir de faire rencontrer ses
plus gros et c'est plus petit pour
pouvoir répondre à nos marchés c'est une
vraiment une stratégie auxquelles on
croit beaucoup pour qu'on livre vraiment
des jeux économiquement et socialement
responsables pour ça évidemment ça veut
dire que on attend une mobilisation de
tous est donc on est vraiment ravis
encore une fois d'être là aujourd'hui
pour partager cette stratégie avec les
entreprises vont la faire comprendre
pour pour montrer aussi qu'il ya un
travail à mener pour répondre à nos
marchés pour être là pour garantir un
maximum ses chances de succès mettre en
relation ces différents groupes
différentes entreprises c'est le coeur
du sky business day justement jean
michel fourgous autour des jeux
olympiques 2024 comment travaille
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour accompagner aussi les
entreprises est ce que vos services
travaillent sur ce sujet je dirais avec
humour en a marre 5 que je lui conseille
d'avoir des petits chefs d'entreprises
autour d'elle
ils vont lui dire tout de suite nous on
veut des choses simples ne lancez pas
dans des questionnements qui ne
correspondent pas leurs objectifs
principaux leurs objectifs en hip hop
c'est de sauver leur boîte c'est de
faire du chiffre d'affaires d'un il va
payer leurs charges qui sont les plus
élevés au monde
pour la france donc voilà après il ya
des d'autres débats mais mais je dirais
que n'idéalisons pas tous les problèmes
de la société
mondiale oui sur une tpe une petite
entreprise donc rester bien dans les
priorités voilà j'entends votre bonne
volonté mais mais on vous rappelle bien
que si on veut les faire réussir elles
sont en danger aujourd'hui avec la crise
que nous avons devant donc il faut
vraiment bien les recentrer il faut les
sauver d'un moment très difficile en
répondant bien précisément alors vrai
problème à eux je dis bien à eux c'est
eux qui sont les priorités les cibles il
faut aider ces petites entreprises et je
connais bien leur culture je peux vous
dire voilà mais ce deal vous posez quand
même mais aussi des problèmes
intéressants ça va être soit il faut
qu'on soit tous solidaires ensemble de
choses ça se dit pourtant saint quentin
moi je dirais que les toutes les
techniques d'accompagnement vous en avez
une ici qui est une un très bon exemple
sur sky business day vous en avez bien
sûr tout une bardée puisque même on a on
a sky emploi on essaye de simplifier
bien entendu la façon de retrouver un
emploi parce que je vous rappelle qu'il
ya un million je crois vous les 10 plus
hauteur de 2,2 dans d'emploi qui ne sont
pas pourvus ce qui est indescriptible
dans un pays qui a 6 millions c'est pas
si millions ça que c'est si milan 6
maintenant de donner de nom d'un emploi
donc voilà faut bien faut bien se rendre
compte et bien se recentrer et est
abandonnée quelques fois des discours un
peu idéologique un peu idéalisée je
dirais voilà aujourd'hui l'économie de
marché c'est prioritaire même sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire il en
faut mais attention ne mettait pas au
même niveau il y en a une qui produit 50
% bien sûr qui redonne 50 % de
l'économie sociale et solidaire il en
faut mais il ne redonne pas 50% bien sûr
ils n'ont pas le même rôle
m rôle économique donc il faut les deux
donc garder les biens à des niveaux
différents il faut il faut bien sûr
aider tout le monde saint quentin le
fait puisqu'on a aussi une antenne
d'économie sociale et solidaire voilà
mes priorités aux petits les gros on l'a
vu on le voit aujourd'hui dans cet
événement les gros font un effort sont
là ils simplifient leurs procédures
n'oubliez pas de simplifier et fait
passer par tous que quand on s'adresse à
une entreprise on doit avoir un discours
de simplification orienté sur leurs
besoins pas sur le pas sur des
idéologues ou d où des fonctionnaires
qui sont complètement déconnectés des
réalités de l'entreprise ont montré bien
que vous êtes là pour réduire bien sûr
ces écarts culturels et de simplifier
toutes les procédures pour faire réussir
ce s'émerveille objectifs que nous avons
tous même bien sûr avait avec le
handicap qui va être traité de façon
exemplaire avec c'est avec ces ccg au
donc pour réussir c'est en tout cas le
la consigne moi que je donne à mon
modeste niveau ces simplifications et
recentrage sur les vraies priorités on
abandonne tout discours idéologique tout
discours d'idéalisation surtout voilà le
message que simon est un peu direct mais
c'est mon style chacun son style en tout
cas 50 ans est assez direct bien sûr
pour bien défendre nos entreprises marie
part ça je reviens vers vous de jean
michel fourgous parler d'emploi les jeux
olympiques on parle de business c'est
aussi de l'emploi ça va créer des
emplois même des services civiques d'ici
à 2024 oui bien sûr derrière l'ambition
économique il y à des emplois quand des
entreprises françaises décrochent des
marchés et des jets on sait que ça peut
générer les emplois c'est déjà le cas
sur un certain nombre de l'entreprise
qui ont décroché nos marchés donc c'est
très enthousiasmant
là le chiffre qui a été évalué par le
centre de droit et d'économie du sport
c'est 150 mille emplois mobilisés pour
les jeux évidemment là encore le pic
d'emploi va être atteint autour de paris
2024 bien sûr puisque c'est là que va se
concentrer le maximum d'activités les
emplois sont un petit peu dans la
construction et le bâtiment autour de 11
mille et ils sont le pic d'activité sur
sur ce secteur là ça sera pour février
2022 et puis ensuite c'est partir de
2023 piquée au tour de l'organisation
des jeux et puis à 2024 là ce qui est le
tourisme la restauration et
l'hébergement donc c'est ça un peu les
emplois
il y a aussi des engagements qui ont été
pris par paris 2004 autour de l'emploi
on a pris deux clauses d'insertion sur
nos marchés en matière de sécurité et de
restauration dont 10 % des heures
travaillées doivent s'adresser à des
personnes en insertion par ces no money
de l'emploi et puis là aussi on a une
stratégie de réserver nos marchés
notamment pour le secteur du handicap et
les secteurs des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi du secteur adapté pour nous
assurer encore une fois qu'on connecte
les personnes qui ont plus de mal à
trouver un emploi à noah nos
opportunités d'emploi donc ça aussi ce
sont des choses que l'on s'est fixés et
sur lesquels moins maintenant on passe à
l'action pour axel pour votre entreprise
jean paul mignard l'emploi ça va générer
des emplois justement
ça doit générer effectivement des
emplois mais les emplois arriveront
après les marchés et après le chiffre
d'affaires aurait même malheureusement
l'habitude de m j'irais là la charrue
avant les boeufs où ils paient pour voir
on ne recrute que lorsqu'on a
effectivement des engagements qui sont
effectivement là et surtout pérenne
puisque on ne veut pas décevoir de
futurs collaborateurs pour ne garder que
quelques mois
mais ce qui est surtout important aussi
a rogné parce que là on évoque
aujourd'hui paris nommé le 24 mai on
évoque des marchés qui sont proposés
mais parmi de 2024 ce ne sont pas que
les marchés qui sont proposés par ce que
parce qu'effectivement paris 2024
proposer des marchés qui vont être
autour de l'activité sportive pure c'est
à dire les sites autour des des sportifs
de la presse qui va être hébergé est
également autour des évidemment des
visiteurs qui vont qui vont venir s'est
déplacé
les marchés ne couvre pas à ma
connaissance tout ce qui est autour des
villes autres et des infrastructures qui
vont être au tour il ya effectivement
des emplois
qui vont venir derrière et nous pour
nous parler 2024 et là je mets un peu le
pied sur la partie ou également sur la
partie héritage est extrêmement
important pour nous sur la partie
accessibilité pmr et on sait que
l'accessibilité en france est un sujet
qui remonte déjà même depuis là
depuis au moins 30 ans est en avance
avec beaucoup de difficultés par
bordeaux mais on aimerait bien au
travers des associations auxquelles je
suis je fais pêche est parti de chez eux
au conseil d'administration de tourisme
handicap je suis également impliqué dans
l'association des professionnels de
l'accessibilité afpap qu' on est en
héritage ce qu'on a de londres en dix
ans avant les jeux de londres
et après les jo n'ont d'accessibilité
des pme oublie c'est plus du tout la
même chose il ya un vrai effet de seuil
et pour nous et pour moi ce qui me
paraît très effectivement extrêmement
important c'est qu'on puisse
ce qui va se passer sur du 24 autour des
infrastructures dans les villes dans les
transports dure dans le temps et
puissante open et nous sommes
actuellement par exemple en
développement d'une nouvelle machine
qui va qui va être présentée très
bientôt à la
ratp sncf qui peut permettre à toute
personne de pouvoir entrer et sortir du
métro du métro sans avoir utilisé un
ascenseur que les ascenseurs sont
absents et ça c'est l'opportunité de
parler du moulin 24 qui va dire demain
grâce à pape diakhaté visiteurs on va
pouvoir développer un nouveau matériel
et qu'on va pouvoir effectivement
utilisées dans le temps et résoudre
peut-être définitivement certains
problèmes de mobilité en france il nous
reste deux minutes pour conclure et
cette ouverture du disque live in sd1
dernier montrait rapidement marie
barsacq jeu sur sur l'héritage
économique justement là aussi votre
structure doit veiller et va veiller à
ce que l'on parlait d'emploi tout à
l'heure et pérennité de ces emplois par
exemple il va falloir s'y atteler oui
tout à fait lorsqu'on appelle un échec
c'est un peu un peu technique mais en
gros il ya un travail qui est fait
autour des emplois mobilisés par les
jeux pour
valoriser leur et accroître leur
employabilité pour qu'ils aient
davantage de passerelles entre
l'événementiel sportif et l'événementiel
ce que culturel en gros aujourd'hui on
essaie de se dire que les personnes qui
vont travailler sur roland garros sur le
tour de france sur la france 2023 en
rugby mais aussi sur des événements
culturels entre 2022 et eux-mêmes 3 2024
et sur paris 2024 bien sûr pour avoir un
contrat plus long terme un cdd long
terme voire un cdi est plutôt que comme
ça se passe aujourd'hui les petits bouts
de contrats de un mois par ci un mois
par là et des périodes de chômage entre
les deux aucun gros travail de
définition parcours de formation et une
plateforme emploi 2024 porté par pôle
emploi qui a été créé et qui a pour
objectif de suivre ces demandeurs
d'emploi qui vont se connecter à des
marchés de l'événementiel sportif
culturel pour les suivre et leur
proposer des contenus de formation pour
aller vers d'autres emplois vers
d'autres événements culturels et
sportifs
ça c'est une action assez structurantes
pour développer du coût des emplois plus
pérenne dans ce secteur parce que vous
le savez le secteur de l'événementiel
est un secteur qui n'est pas attractif
parce que les salaires sont très haut
c'est vrai mais aussi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de précarité avec des ampoules
et des contrats qui se succèdent et qui
ne permettent pas de donner du coût de
la visibilité dans le temps à ceux qui
les emploient parce qu'il est est ce
vrai merci c'est ce qu'ils aimeraient ce
qu'est le business des 6e mais édition
l'ouverture et est donc faite jean
michel fourgous le mot de la fin en 15
secondes très très vite attention bien
sûr restons clairement la priorité c'est
les emplois marchands vous avez trois
mille milliards de dettes c'est hors
norme vous avez 200 m illiard déficit
budgétaire attention on est en zone de
danger on veut des emplois qui ont une
pérennité et seul le secteur marchand
peut assurer une pérennité parce que il
autofinance alors que d'autres
structures si elles vivent que de
subventions ces subventions ont
forcément baisser avec niveaux de
déficit et de dette que vous avez bon
donc faut bien dire la vérité à nos
jeunes il faut les arrêter massivement
en sortie sur des emplois marchands et y
en a dans la culture il y en a bien sûr
dans toutes les activités que vous avez
cités mais mais voilà soyez très
vigilant là dessus parce que vous allez
avoir des surprises dans les six mois
dans les huit mois après ces élections
vous aurez un bilan économique réelle de
la france je sais qu'il est quand même
très difficile j'ai passé 15 ans à la
commission des finances comme député je
et j'ai encore un réseau là dessus donc
voilà préparez-vous comme un des moments
difficiles orienter massivement la
protection sous les emplois marchands
voilà merci à nos trois invités qui est
aujourd'hui étaient présents en plateau
pour l'ouverture de ce sky business
d'elle l'événement se poursuit toute la
journée en ligne puis sur cette antenne
également à partir de 15h30 une émission
autour dû jouer collectif un moyen pour
être plus performant réseau associatif
conseil en entreprise ou encore
dirigeants de clusters interviendront et
puis à 18 heures toujours sur cette
antenne dans notre journal nous ferons
le bilan de cet événement d'ici là très
belle journée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]